جاء اليوم الذي يهابه الجميع في بريطانيا
فبعد يومين من اضرابات القطاع الصحي التي
انهكت اعصاب المرضى وعائلاتهم تبدا
واضراباتهم موظفي مطار وسط تحذيرات من
فوضى عارمه قد تواجه المسافرين في الايام
الاخيره من العام منهم من الغى رحلته
ومنهم من غير موعدها املا في تجنب
الطوابير التي حذر مسؤولون انها قد تزيده
عن الساعتين
نحو الفا من موظفي المطارات ومراقبه
الجوازات يضربون عن العمل لمده سته ايام
من اخر اسبوع في السنه
مطالبهم تتلخصوا برفع اجورهم بنسبه 10%
بعد عجز العديد منهم عن توفير اساسيات
معيشتهم
[موسيقى]
اضرابات تتصاعد وتيرتها في مواجهه ما
اعتبرته النقابات تعنتا حكميا ضد رفع اجور
عمالها
فسناك يبدو متمسكا بموقفه من ازمه رفع
الاجور معتبرا ان تحقيق مطالب العمال
سيفاقموا من ازمه التضخم في البلاد
تحدي الاقتصادي الرئيسي الذي نواجهه جميعا
الان هو التضخم وبالتالي هدف التقليل من
التضخم مما يعني وجوب اتخاذ قرار مسؤول
فيما يتعلق برواتب القطاع
العامريه ان هناك لازال يتعامل مع الازمه
كوزينا للماليه وليس كرئيس للوزراء حيث
تطالب مختلف النقابات برفع الاجور بمعدل
يتوافقوا مع معدل التضخمه في البلاد فيما
يعتبر السوناك انه ملتزم بقرار الهيئه
المختصه برفع الاجور والتي وضعت الزياده
عند اثنين وخمسه في المئه فقط نسبه
تعتبرها نقابه بحقهم
اختار العديد في بريطانيا تجنب السفر او
تقريب موعد رحلاتهم تجنبا لاضرابات
بريطانيا وفوضى مطاراتها التي انهكت
الزائرين والمقيمين ومع تهديد النقابات
بالمزيد من الاضرابات خلال الاسابيع
والشهور المقبله توجه الحكومه البريطانيه
اختبارات ما بين تحقيق مطالب العمال او
اعطاء الاولويه للاقتصاد عروب عبد الحق
العربيه